[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa con
más romeros a la mar bienvenida a
felices jueves ya casi acabando esta
semana que rápido se están pasando los
días ya de cara a diciembre qué rico de
diciembre cierto mal pues por supuesto y
además trabajando con nosotros se pasan
muy rápidas y muy rápido ganas buen
equipo de trabajo tenemos mar pero ahora
comenzamos con una noticia muy reciente
hace minutos el regulador europeo
recomendó la vacuna de facer para niños
y niñas entre los 5 y 11 años más
seguimos hablando de las vacunas del coi
19 la pandemia y no se acaba no
claramente no y de hecho precisamente es
uno de los motivos que ha llevado a la
agencia europea del medicamento a
recomendar esta vacuna básicamente lo
que han hecho es hablar es una
recomendación emitida para los gobiernos
de la unión europea para que vacunen a
los niños entre los 5 y los 11 años con
facer con una dosis menor también una
dosis que sería un tercio de la que se
aplican a los adultos son varios los
países que ya están vacunando a los
niños en estos rangos de edades de eeuu
por ejemplo pero también en américa
latina donde se está usando fighter
también se ha aprobado en países de
américa latina para estos niños y
también la de sinovac que recordemos que
es una vacuna de virus inactivado y que
hace tiempo que también ya se sabe que
es segura para los niños esta decisión
de la agencia europea del medicamento se
suma a la de ayer de recomendar las
dosis de refuerzo para todos los adultos
europeos y esto pues desde un punto de
vista más analítico también puede
responder a que europa se ha convertido
en el nuevo epicentro de la pandemia y
en un intento raúl de contener la
transmisión de este virus ahora que
además se acerca navidad se acerca el
frío y las fiestas así es mari
precisamente sobre la transmisión del
coi 19 tenemos más datos concretos de
qué datos estamos hablando pues los dio
ayer a la organización mundial de la
salud que recordó además que la variante
delta sigue siendo un peligro no y
advirtió pues sobre sus consecuencias
escuchemos los datos que dieron
boxing save lives las vacunas salvan
vidas pero no previenen completamente la
transmisión los datos muestran que antes
de la llegada de la variante delta las
vacunas reducían la transmisión en un
60% transmisión volts sixty per cent con
delta esa cifra ha caído hasta el 40%
bout force y percent
importante recordar también que la
variante delta ya es predominante en
muchísimos pues en la mayoría de países
de europa de eeuu y también en américa
latina está empezando a causar estragos
precisamente más vamos a hablar de
américa latina porque en los organismos
internacionales hicieron anuncios sobre
la distribución de las vacunas contra el
commit 19 en la región muy desigual esta
distribución más exacto eso sigue sin
ser una novedad lo hemos venido hablando
desde hace tiempo pero bueno la
organización panamericana de la salud ha
anunciado unas cosas para intentar poner
solución a eso recordemos por ejemplo
que hay países en américa latina como
chile donde el 80% de su población está
vacunado y otros como haití que no
llegan ni siquiera al 1% son países
dependientes de estas donaciones además
en un contexto donde el mecanismo kóvacs
funcionando del todo es hablar entregado
un tercio de lo que habían prometido
para 2021 y por eso la organización
panamericana de la salud está buscando
acuerdos bilaterales con las
farmacéuticas para distribuir más
vacunas en la región escuchemos lo que
dijeron
las negociaciones de la pf con las
empresas que producen vacunas siguen
bien avanzadas ya tenemos acuerdos
firmados con tres nuestra técnica con su
nueva que se mofaron y estamos para
cerrar un nuevo acuerdo con una
productora de vacunas de línea aérea en
un mensajero este acuerdo sólo es para
estar pendiente la confirmación de las
cantidades por parte de los países pues
nada esperaremos a ver cuál de estas
farmacéuticas es la que va a dar más
vacunas a la audiencia también vamos a
ver qué pasa mar y terminamos con el
internacional para eliminar la violencia
contra la mujer nuestro primer tema del
día un problema de salud pública le
pregunto más pues efectivamente si la
organización mundial de la salud por
ejemplo lo considera así por las grandes
consecuencias que tienen la salud de las
mujeres y por la magnitud de las cifras
de cómo nos afecta a todas cerramos lo
ampliaremos mañana pero por ahora
cerramos con algunos datos alarmantes
por ejemplo y es que decíamos eso que un
tercio de las mujeres son víctimas de
violencia física o sexual en todo el
mundo para ponerlo en a 82 millones de
mujeres reciben un diagnóstico de cáncer
al año son 275 las que viven actualmente
con enfermedades cardiovasculares y si
esto lo comparamos con la cantidad de
mujeres que han sido víctimas de
violencia física o machista en el mundo
esas son más de 730 millones esa cifra
equivale a 90 años de diagnósticos
acumulados por ejemplo de casos de
cáncer en mujeres por esos motivos por
esas cifras tan alarmantes raúl es que
decimos que la violencia machista es un
problema de salud pública mañana
seguimos con más 100% mar por favor y
rechazamos absolutamente todo tipo de
violencia más a la mujer gracias madre
entonces mañana seguimos ampliando ese
tema vamos ahora bla